e
[Musica]
chi
no non ha funzionato
non è servito a niente prendere questa
bambola
e dato un bene
chi è stato a parlare sono quasi ma io
qualcuno va giù dove ma per te
sono io la bambola non mi riconosci
no non riconosce la mia nuovo c'è
umanità a vita perché mi stai parlando
dalla bambola perché mi ha intrappolato
ha detto lei la pampa la cattiva ha
cambiato i nostri corpi ora la bambola e
nel corpo della vita cioè il mio corpo
invece io unità sono dentro questa
bambola come dobbiamo fare a far tornare
le cose come erano prima
quello che sto cercando di capire
l'unico modo e tornare da anita cioè non
a vita dalla palco la cattiva e cercare
di ricambiare i corpi altrimenti dovrò
rimanere rinchiusa in questa favola di
plastica per tempo devi darmi ok ma cosa
dobbiamo fare dobbiamo trovare qualcosa
tipo un amuleto che magari vi faccia
ritornare su anita nel tuo corpo nella
bambola nella bambola giustamente esatto
uomo elaborare un piano altrimenti
rischio di rimanere intrappolata qui
però c'è una cosa che ho notato non vedi
che mi manca qualcosa
che cosa ti manca
guarda non ho più la collana prima avevo
la collana addosso e ora non so dove è
finita forse potrebbe essere quello
l'amuleto che ci serve è vero non ci
avevo pensato trebbe essere proprio
quello in effetti dove sarà ho un'idea
potrebbe essere che lei l'ha presa e
l'ha nascosta da qualche parte quindi
l'unico modo è restituirmi a lei
purtroppo e non farle credere che stiamo
collaborando assieme
ok ok mi sembra un'ottima idea povero
sciocco non sai che in realtà io non ho
più bisogno di quella bambola renzi
molto migliorati e portato
ho deciso di ridare una bambola beh però
in cambio di qualcosa e governato
facciamo uno scambio
quello che sei
ma pensavo fosse la tua migliore amica
avevi detto come sorelle ne importa
ottenuta
[Musica]
aspetta aspetta guardala non vorresti
solo bisogno di qualcosa in cambio
[Musica]
insomma metta
in cambio
sentiamo bene ecco guardavano niente io
dicevo siccome hai dei bellissimi
capelli come la bambola certo i tuoi
sono più belli e per carità ci avete la
stessa giacchetta il vestitino che meno
si limita molto bello stai molto bene ti
volevo dire però ho notato che se stai
benissimo è proprio bellissimi questi
capelli davvero ben più belli della
bambola
io ho aiutato però che manca qualcosa
guarda io ti darei in cambio le bambole
appunto se lui mi daresti quel qualcosa
che manca alla bambola che ha
praticamente che l'inter abbia nota
arrabbiare nel senso che aveva notato
che manca un
piccolissimo dettaglio nella bambola
praticamente manca manca la sua collana
ho detto collana
collana
che
[Musica]
va beh voglio dire non è che ci vogliono
avevano un genio divertirete che marca
la collana
vai dove
purtroppo penso come fai a sapere
bernacconi e
magnetico
io però io non so niente devo giuro at t
non dovreste riuscire a muovermi in one
guardatevi a muoversi non potete
addio
rispettando
non lasciarci qua così come voglio
mangiare adesso mi sa che non è stata
una buona idea dirla dalla collana lo so
ma era l'unico modo per riuscire ad
avere la collana e ora non ci resta che
provare a liberarci e cercarla tanto a
me è un peccato solo le braccia quindi
dovrei riuscire ad alzarmi guardare qui
intorno in camera magari riusciamo a
trovare qualcosa tipo un'idea cerchiamo
il telefono in ascolta fa nella
cameretta ma spieghiamo sui prima che
ritorni stendete che ti sei alzato in
piedi che stai cercando la collana è
arrabbiata 10mo si ci prova de vivo
potrei cadere ci
prova allora potremmo vedere qua intorno
se vedi qualcosa avvisa mia potrebbe
essere qua
no qui non c'è mi ha però a guardare
ritiene compatti non hai la mente
accordo come diego patti per bolide
vediamo
no non mi sembra di vedere niente qui da
me potrebbe essere qui è meglio la prima
scusami
non c'è niente vuoi bene
sto bene sono una
rubrica
dove di qualcosa che ho dentro dalla
matita
cielo sulla chiave
europea ma deve aprire per cosa non lo
so però se abbiamo bisogno di una chiave
in miniatura equa ehi guardate
mitigato la sua testa è ottimo allora
contano non meno tasse conterebbero 39
nelle tasche del latte anche alla
collana non controlla da una nota prende
anche questa non c'è niente l'ho girato
dall'altra parte
no non c'è mica qui ma anche se non c'è
niente nella giacca
io direi di nascondere la sacca tenera
ma noi così nel caso che ci minaccia se
potevo ricattarla con la polacca l'ha
nascosto sotto il letto allora
che lanciò
bene continuiamo a cercare dove potrebbe
essere la collana
[Musica]
salve
giorno
cercando
non stavo cercando la collana stava
cercando dalla madre ma vana perché una
caduta mi manca ancora da persone care
tiferò per
chi siamo e cosa facciamo adesso
dobbiamo riuscire a trovare la collana o
di idea
la mia unica idea
sarà un po strano però il loro trono di
caos quindi accorta mi pensi ti ascolto
devi fare esattamente quarto
è in bambola e alita esempio questo so
come tu come ti potevo chiamare oltre ci
sono mi voglio voglio essere dalla tua
parte
voglio trasformarmi anch'io in bambola e
quindi sarò il suo tour su al suo il tuo
al tuo al tuo servizio è potrei mettermi
a belli biondi e farò quello che vuoi ok
ma se michele per permettere l
siediti ok
di sicuro che avrà un'idea questa che
cosa vuole dirmi
futuro sì non preoccuparti anzi ho già
visto dove la collana noi vi siete
accorti di dove ha la collana guardate
bene
state bene attenti per accorgerete anche
voi ok mi fido di te poi lasciato mi
piace per portarmi fortuna però è adesso
per me
sara bellissimo
bellissimo
td capelli per
anche di belle arti
ei
accusa mi sono dimenticata
no grazie che gentile
all'oriente un look sono sempre quindi
chi ha i capelli che belli ed effettiva
io in questo caso non hanno avuto
colombelli
altre sono tutte le più belle capitali
[Musica]
grazie
gentilissima
gravità sì grazie grazie ho capito tutto
adesso e cioè grazie di avermi
vita ho capito che sono tuo servizio
grazie e quindi adesso io sono libero di
andare vero no
finita la trasformazione solo ma chi ha
i capelli biondi il 20 di essere una mia
bambola già di superarli prendere molto
alti
io non pertinenti per bene e
d'ambiente nei capelli degli occhi
ho visto lato umana c'erano il polso
come braccialetto io lo avevo visto
anch'io
ora devi provare 8 reti appena so che
sarà difficile ma provate non approvo le
pa via d'uscita ok va bene adesso che si
avvicina proverò a toglierselo hatay e
cosa è un cappello bianco che avevi
nella barucca ho detto del mero velotto
agli altri
volevo dire è come lo bianco e belli
maisto mattei fermo come non vivono di
questi capelli ok sto fermo
vediamo
il calore ti piacerebbe mi aspetto mia
gamba non lo so che come rai noi abbiamo
rosso viola e
opponete stesso con la recchia che invia
le
[Musica]
impronte si mangia 6 pronti a muggia che
vedono a prenderlo subito
non riesco a prenderlo per aiutarmi mi
posso fare
per aiutarti
ascoltami medici di mi
è presa rossetto
o ridotto brugia questa rosa a questa è
e come si mangia
hi fi tempo un momento non bello
insomma non riesco a metterti bene un
affetto sono stai fermo e poi a termine
non ha nome e
tartaro basta basta rossetto
tutto andare hai giurato fedeltà e
divorate di essere diventare una mia
bambola aiuta i pezzi quindi non
coinvolga nessuna parte ma cronopio non
sono più stiamo guarda un po
come esatto quando hai tolto
metti il rossetto
dovevo fidarmi
rega ma la storica
chi sta succedendo mi di scappare
abbiamo
finito
di
protesta direi anche questo aspetto
è quello bambola
cosa sta succedendo per concordare una
lunga storia però mentre ti spiego
dobbiamo sbarazzarci di alcune cose ok
ora capisco allora perché sono vestita e
truccata così pesci perché tu dov'eri la
mafia è quel rossetto bene adesso
liberiamoci di questa bambola vero
quindi se ho capito bene abbiamo ripreso
la scatola che non deve essere aperta
per mettere dentro la bambola e farla
sparire attobre sia ok funzionerà sempre
lo stesso modo però io spero proprio di
sì
una due tre
ma
è fuori pericolo
bene ha fatto anche questa volta ora
possiamo stare a mangiare sappiamo che
andiamo andiamo a mangiare
[Musica]
o